Johnny Depp arriving in Australia last  month on a private jet with his wife  Amber Heard the u.s. star is filming the  fifth installment of the blockbuster  movie series Pirates of the Caribbean  unbeknownst to customs officials Depp's  Yorkshire Terriers pistol and Boo were  also on the plane the consequences for  breaking Australia's strict quarantine  regulations could be dying we found out  he snuck them in because we saw them  taking it to a poodle groomer now mr.  Depp has to either take his dogs back to  California or we're gonna have to  euthanize them the agriculture minister  also said he doesn't expect to be  invited to the movie's premiere